this video is made possible by blinkers
the first hundred people to go to
blinkers calm forward-slash visual
politic are going to get unlimited
access for one week to try it out you'll
also get 25% off if you want the full
membership more about that later
for now let's get on with it
[Applause]
[Music]
Japan is the country with the greatest
reason to be scared of nuclear power
think about it they have the biggest
nuclear trauma record in the world
[Music]
so bath they are the only country that
has suffered a nuclear attack namely the
Hiroshima and Nagasaki bombings in fact
during the 50s nuclear paranoia was big
in Japan the most famous outcome of this
is the movie Godzilla the story of a
gigantic radioactive lizard that
destroys cities nonetheless as the
Japanese economy grew Japan started
building its own reactors a couple of
decades later they became the third
biggest nuclear power house only
surpassed by America and France yep you
heard that right while European
countries like Germany were organizing
all kinds of anti-nuclear demonstrations
Japan blindly a trusted uranium
[Music]
but then as the Japanese were being
charmed by atomic power the unexpected
happens Japan Earthquake explosion at
Fukushima power plant a powerful
explosion has hit a nuclear power
station in northeastern Japan which is
badly damaged in Friday's devastating
earthquake and tsunami overnight a
nuclear panic came back to Japan into
the whole world and that was a good
reason for it you see during the
Chernobyl accident in 1986 many people
said that the problem is a nuclear power
is the fact that Chernobyl didn't follow
the security protocols
you know the Soviets but Japan it's a
wealthy country that takes extreme care
with its security and despite all of
this Fukushima we're still a disaster
all of a sudden Japan shut down all of
their nuclear power plants they went
from having 30% nuclear power in the
energy mix to just a tiny 3% so now you
might assume that Japan is turning into
an anti-nuclear country right well as
you might have guessed the opposite is
actually true
[Music]
20 to 22 percent share of nuclear power
at core of updated energy policy nuclear
power has come back to Japan in fact not
only Japan as we said in previous videos
the whole Asian continent is going
through a nuclear revolution and when I
say the whole continents I really mean
it from wealthy countries like Japan to
poor countries like Bangladesh and this
is surprising if we take into account
that nuclear reactors were far from
cheap in this other video we told you
about what's going on in China but today
we're going to focus on what's happening
in the two other biggest Asian countries
Japan and India because the question we
want to address today is what about
nuclear power appeals to Asians so much
and how is India still a poor country
become such a nuclear power house well
today we are going to answer these
questions but before we do there's
always let's take a look back at the
history the nuclear giant is back
Fukushima meant an immediate nuclear
shutdown the Japanese wanted to minimize
risk and stopped all their reactors
basically overnight same are you
wondering well where if they'd gotten
their energy from since then I mean how
did they replace the energy input that
they used to get from nuclear power well
the answer is complete ecological Harry
Caray yep you heard that right
if you thought nuclear power was bad for
the environment most of the alternatives
they're even worse
without uranium Japan had to start using
fossil fuels and this had two
consequences electricity prices rose 20%
because suddenly they had to buy tons of
liquefied natural gas the other
consequence was that co2 emissions
absolutely skyrocketed in other words if
Godzilla happened to show up in
Fukushima he would have to wear a mask
and I know what you might be thinking
why don't they use renewable sources I
mean what's the problem with green
energy well the problem is time if you
want to have solar panels and wind
turbines first you have to build them
and Japan is far behind other countries
in this regard
in fact is only now that they're
starting their green energy plan their
goal is to achieve 22% of their energy
from renewable sources by 2030 for
comparison Europe plans to achieve the
same in 2020 how mainly because Europe
started investing in these technologies
way sooner but only that even if Japan
wanted to speed up their green energy
plan they couldn't one of their main
problems is red tape want to start a
wind turbine park well you need five
years of paper work to be done this is
three times longer than most
industrialized countries and reducing
the red tape there it's almost
impossible
[Music]
and also let's not forget the classic
problem with green energy and that's
that it's incredibly expensive to store
electricity using these methods for
example solar panels only give you
energy during the day and the same goes
for wind turbines you only get energy
when it's windy during a calm night you
still need to use other energy sources
so realistically Japan has only two
options fan er G they can keep important
expensive gas and polluting like crazy
or they can go nuclear and the answer it
seems to be a bit of a no-brainer for
them
Japan restarts 5 nuclear power reactors
in 2018 in total at the time we made
this video Japan has already restarted 9
nuclear reactors but it's not only that
they're restarting at the capacity they
previously have they want to build even
more process begins at sh'mon a nuclear
plant to operate new reactor you see
when you're talking about nuclear power
there's one important thing you must
understand they produce energy on an
ongoing basis this means from the moment
you start a reactor you have the same
amount of energy every single day no
more no less this is why nuclear power
is considered the base of an electrical
system turning off a nuclear reactor is
very expensive and it's only done when
there's a real risk of an accident
that's why they're always producing
energy
[Music]
and you put on top of that nuclear
energy other energy sources such as coal
gas or green energy these are energy
sources that can be adjusted based on
the energy demands of a particular day
nevertheless if we said green energy
depends on the weather
coal or gas depends on market prices and
these fluctuate daily nonetheless you
just need a little piece of uranium to
have nuclear power so price fluctuations
on this material they don't affect the
cost that much this is the reason why
Japan is going back to nuclear but it's
not only Japan in South Korea they're
also mastering this form of energy while
in North Korea they build nukes their
southern neighbors built reactors in
total they have six of them and I am I
wonder well who builds all these nuclear
power plants I mean the truth is that
nuclear power it's really complicated
and it's really expensive and indeed
there are very few companies that have
mastered these technologies remember
those reactors built by Japan in the
1960s well they were built by British
and American companies for years General
Electric and Westinghouse dominated the
market but soon Toshiba
Hitachi and Mitsubishi started their own
generation of models South Korea
followed suits they started buying
American French and Canadian models but
then I owned I do CERN and kepco started
manufacturing their own reactors now
South Korea is another nuclear power
house that exports the technology all
over the world
[Music]
UAE and South Korea celebrate completion
of Baraka's first nuclear reactor and I
knew I was a well okay but how much does
a nuclear reactor cost to give you an
idea all of the reactors that they want
to build in the Arabian Peninsula cost
twenty billion dollars this is about the
cost of hosting the Olympic Games by the
way just to make you embarrassed in a
fossil fuel plant that generates the
same amounts of energy costs 20 times
less of course producing a kilowatt of
electricity with nuclear power is the
cheapest way to do so but the initial
outlay is only affordable to very rich
economies so then how on earth is it
possible that India and Bangladesh can
have nuclear reactors well let's have a
look
[Music]
from Godzilla to go Cola
Japan has Godzilla India has go Cola if
you didn't know after the commercial
success of Godzilla Bollywood created
their own exploitation version and this
is the giant Cola
[Music]
but enough with the movies when it comes
to energy we've got the same story if
Japan had nuclear power plants India
wanted the same the problem American
companies didn't want to sell reactors
to India why
mainly because India has nukes yep you
heard that right the country of Gandhi
and non-violence is one of the few
nations with nukes and their biggest
enemy Pakistan also has them so there's
a real danger that one day they're going
to use them in other words America
doesn't want to help India go even more
nuclear but that's not even the most
interesting part you see unlike Japan
and South Korea India has its own
uranium mines so since America didn't
want to help them they went to France
and to Russia this is why many of the
nuclear reactors in India are built by a
rasa tahn the Russian company but here's
the really interesting part Indian
reactors have something very special
about them they're cheaper than anywhere
else why because they're the only ones
that use natural uranium you see most of
the world's reactors use enriched
uranium this is uranium that cannot be
used to manufacture nuclear bombs and
this is why buying and rich uranium is
sort of easy but there are many
restrictions to get natural uranium you
see if you go to buy natural uranium
someone's gonna be like whoa whoa hold
on a second there cowboy what exactly
you're gonna use that for because since
India has its own uranium they can do
whatever they want with it this is why
their natural uranium reactors away
cheaper and it explains news like this
[Music]
India plans tenfold uranium output
growth India is currently building seven
nuclear reactors but they plan to build
20 more as I said they're using mainly
Russian technology bands as you know
since Rossi tom was doing business in
the region they went to neighboring
Bangladesh and they made this Raza Tom
starts work on unit two of Bangladesh
end project with this Vangel adesh will
cover 20% of their energy demands with
nuclear power and the same is happening
in Pakistan dorama our previous video
where we told you how China is starting
to create its own nuclear technology
well Pakistan is the one buying from the
Chinese in other words nuclear power is
not a rich country business anymore
is getting crazy over us so I really
hope you enjoyed that video it's made
possible of course by blankest do you
manage to read all of the books that you
want to read probably not right we all
lead busy lives and that can sometimes
mean you don't get the knowledge you
need it's harder and harder to find the
time to learn in the modern world I mean
all of those distracting videos over
there on the left somewhere really
tempting to click on the good news is
that even if you don't have time you can
still learn with blinkers blinkers is an
app that takes the best insight to
need-to-know info from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15 minutes which you can either
read or you can listen to they have a
huge library and they've got eight
million users for me I'm probably the
ideal blinkers customer I spent a lot of
time working making these videos and far
less time learning than I probably
should they got tons of popular titles
like the 4-hour workweek from Tim
Ferriss one I read a while ago and
recaps recently there's also tons of
political books if you want to take a
look back at the history like we say
here on visual politic they've got books
condensed like the Silk Roads by Peter
Frank upon the first 100 people to go to
blink is calm forward smashing visual
politic you're going to get unlimited
access for one week to try it out you'll
also get 25% off the full membership
move fast
grab on those political books or well
whatever you want really the seven day
trial is completely free and you can
cancel at any time during that trial if
you're not satisfied but you know I'm
sure you're well be and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]